so
do
so
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
feet
[Music]
uh
so
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
don't
uh
that's
[Music]
foreign
1
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my oh
[Music]
so
one
[Music]
[Music]
strap in folks this game's for all the
marbles
he's on the breakaway the shot for the
win
yes the fans are rushed
uh the doors are open but nobody panic
no panicking because uh oh no
okay it's time for opening act um um
where is our opening act
anybody anybody sayonara wild hearts
you're off
let's get this show started
hi everyone thanks for tuning in my name
is yulathaning
i'm going to play a few songs that i
wrote together with donnie lucian for
the video game cyanura wild hearts
developed by simogo enjoy
[Music]
everything is strange
[Music]
the end of love
doesn't happen this way
[Music]
how do you say
goodbye
[Music]
so long
[Music]
begin again
begin again again
again again
i can
[Music]
december so
[Music]
we didn't know
[Music]
that it was
stone we ever told
would unfold
[Music]
[Music]
cause i'm just happy to begin again
again again again again
[Music]
crystal clear
[Music]
key
don't you know how it goes
[Music]
it's the last time
[Music]
and strangely all
[Music]
where
[Music]
[Music]
and i'm strangely all right
[Music]
cause i'm just happy to begin again
again again begin again again
[Music]
what's the word does nothing
happen
when familiar surroundings
don't look the same do you think that
it's strange
it's my way i suppose
i'm just longing for a place
[Music]
i don't know
[Music]
come on
i don't know
thank you so much
okay that was great but uh let's just
keep this moving along here
um where is jeff jeff keely
anybody i think it's pronounced keeley
spelled strangely but i think that's
right um
can someone find jeff please okay
uh well q the graphics
[Music]
hey guys it's jeff keeley and welcome to
the summer game fest july
developer showcase this is a great event
because we get to show a ton of games to
you across the entire industry
from small and bigger studios we've got
miss
piggy coming up as a special guest you
already saw
uh scooter from the muppets thanks for
stage managing scooter
uh and we've got the world premiere
performance of
it's bug snacks the theme song for that
uh
game coming up very soon so lots of
great stuff today
but first
[Applause]
uh hi uh yeah glitch from rogue company
right i think we just saw you in the
nintendo direct
that's right mr keely and now i'm coming
directly
to you uh
i already stepped into the spotlight but
i've got even more real company info to
show off today
today why not do it right now here in
the developer showcase we're ready
jeff of course we've kept this recruit
on lockdown
what better way to unlock her than with
a key
we introducing ronin all right
sounds good uh okay take a look
sorry jeff i have your pc read today's
script
man i can't wait for those announcements
no no we're not getting into that right
now let's let's focus on this new rogue
please can we do that live feed
beginning
now
no you can't use the bathroom and no we
don't have wi-fi
we hear you carry only finest
merchandise
welcome to esa home to the world's most
exclusive collection of top-tier
munitions
so how can i help you i'm looking to
make a statement
mission accomplished oh but you're here
to accessorize
the p12k works with any ensemble
that's like the mom genes of guns
statement
remember right something more street
style then
the arbiter is in season
perhaps something from our high volume
line
nope the fully customizable mamba ac
rifle
side folding polymer stock free floated
mil-step barrel
advanced dual beam laser sight the
perfect tactical weapon too many plastic
parts
glasses would shake it
[Music]
it's time to go shall i wrap that up to
you
nah i'll wear it out
excuse me ma'am you overpaid the extras
for the door
you should duck
[Music]
uh
[Music]
here we go
there's the big news rogue company is
available today in early access
across four platforms and joining us
right now on
its big launch day is first watch games
and scott from the team
uh scott i know you're a new studio
sister studio to the smite team
uh this is this is exciting um
tell us a bit about your vision for
rogue company what kind of game is it
so yeah first and foremost we are a
third person
round based shooter but what we're
bringing to the table here is that we
have a unique blend between
action gameplay and tactical shooting
uh and you're also bringing that action
gameplay tactical shooting
to four platforms uh right here at the
beginning
uh tell us a bit about that yeah so
today we are launching and
with going out on all four platforms we
are actually going to be launching with
cross play and cross progression which
is something that we hold very close to
our hearts at first watch games
we want people to be able to play the
game they want with their friends
regardless of the platform it's one of
the worst experiences
of all time is trying to figure out like
what platform your friends playing on
and if you can play with them
you just want you to be able to play the
game you want and we saw you on the
nintendo direct i know you're doing
60 frames per second on the switch and
all other platforms too
that is correct so one of the goals we
had and so a big pillar has always been
cross-play cross progression and so in
order to make that
you know fair across the board is we
need the same experience for everybody
and we wanted to bring 60 fps
including to the switch on both handheld
and docked and i'm happy to say
that we actually were able to achieve
that goal let's talk about some of the
characters we just saw that great
cg piece from the team at blur with
ronin and dima uh who are those
characters
so yeah a little bit about them so ronan
is the newest recruit to road company
and so her and dima are kind of showing
off a little bit of their arsenal
but what's important to the gameplay
here is that they are two of 12
rogues that road company will have at
lunch and
just a little bit about a lure here the
rogues go where the governments can't
and what that ultimately means is you
know the rogues look good they save the
day
and they get paid uh road company early
access
today servers are online that is correct
i can't believe those words came out of
my mouth but yes you can become a
founder today
by getting the game on either the
nintendo switch playstation 4
xbox one or pc via epic game store
awesome all right scott first watch
games congratulations on launch we will
see you online
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's the news overcooked all you can
eat it is coming to
xbox series x and playstation 5
later this year and to tell us a bit
more about it we've got
ollie and phil from ghost town games and
rusty from team 17 to talk about this
uh hey guys how you doing i i like you
got the
uh phil you got your game award there we
match
oh wow yeah who put that there get game
award winning title overcooked and well
deserved uh
this game is so much fun you guys have
done such a great job over the years
with it and we're excited about this
this new version so let's get into it um
you know a next-gen version of overcook
but it looks like you've taken
all the overcooked one content and and
moved it to the overcooked 2 engine and
i understand this is like a complete
remaster like all the art's been redone
and everything
yeah that's right we basically had this
uh this plan that we were going to take
over code 2 and and bring it out on the
the new consoles on series x and on ps5
and we really sort of took a look at uh
what we've created
up to now since the release of the first
game in 2016.
um you know when me and ollie made that
that first game ourselves
uh there was a lot of sort of rough
edges it was it was very much a
shoestring budget kind of game
uh so that when we had this opportunity
to remaster overcooked too we were like
well you know what we'd really like to
go back in
and just revisit a lot of that content
from the first game
uh so that we could you know bring it up
to not just the quality of
overcooked ii but kind of go beyond that
as well and bring up to the quality
people expect for
you know the new consoles yeah so uh
tell us a bit about uh what we can
expect in this
obviously it's got all the basically
everything you've released from
overcooked is in this package right
that's right yeah so it includes all of
overcooked and it includes
all of the dlcs are overcooked as well
as all of overcooked too
uh one of the big things that we could
do with uh remaking the game in sort of
overcooked two's engine and then sort of
bringing that up is that we could add
online multiplayer which obviously we
had to do from like reconstructing the
game from scratch because the original
game didn't support online multiplayer
um so that was one of the big things we
wanted to bring in in this as well as
the crash platform cross-platform stuff
rusty one thing i i read about that i i
wanted to give you guys a chance to talk
about was the accessibility in this game
that's something that i think we've all
been thinking about a lot as an industry
of how to make
games more accessible and you guys have
put some effort into the accessibility
of the game can you tell us a bit about
that
yeah 100 it's been it's really important
for us to to have the game
be accessible to every single person
that plays it um
so not only have we added an assist mode
which is obviously great for
families um people with disabilities to
play which is fantastic
but we've also looked at adding colour
blindness options uh dyslexia font
things like this
i think it's massively important for us
to support these these features going
forward
all right well uh this is exciting we
love to see overcooked continue
uh thanks for coming on uh day of the
devs and being part of uh
summer game fest ollie phil and rusty
ghost town games uh i'm sure this is
probably not the last we've seen them
overcooked but
we'll take this year's menu and see
what's in store for the future thanks
guys
thank you very much joining us now is
someone you probably won't ever find in
the kitchen although she did have a
cookbook once
but if you're a major star like her
someone else of course does the cooking
please welcome to summer game fest miss
piggy moon
hello my fellow gamers
fellow gamers miss piggy i had no idea i
never pegged you as a video game player
i thought you'd be far too busy filming
muppets now streaming july 31st on
disney plus it's fabulous
yes of course it is we're excited about
that but piggy i must say you don't
strike me as the gaming type
oh really oh really jeffrey i don't and
i suppose you don't think i'm a game
player
just because i'm a woman no
miss piggy uh of course not i just think
i've never heard you talk about games
before i guess
is this a new thing for you it's always
been a secret hobby uh
jeff i will have you know that i have
over
100 platinum trophies on my ps4
i adore platinum i i know that but i
didn't know about the trophies that's
fascinating yeah i've met all
the greats hideo kojima and i had sushi
in tokyo
miyamoto-san and i are besties and
strictly between those
my series pigs in space was the
inspiration for todd howard's upcoming
star field
yep i'm a little shocked by that i have
to say
yeah well i am shocking
well listen miss piggy uh today we're
here to celebrate lots of great
independent game developers with
the day of the devs and girls make
games an organization that inspires
young girls to pursue
careers in the video game industry just
like moi
well it is a great organization we're so
proud to support that
uh piggy have you ever thought about
developing your own game to inspire
young women yourself well you know what
i say about devolving
anything worth doing is worth having
someone else do it for you
that certainly does sound like you but i
do perform
in video games yeah yeah yeah uh let me
give you a line reading and uh
yeah hear this
the cake is a lie the cake
is a lie brilliant
a game award-winning performance ladies
and gentlemen thanks again to the star
of muppets now coming to disney plus
on july 31st miss piggy i wonder if that
cake has buttercream frosting
oh boy that would be great i am famished
last month we announced that avatar the
last airbender was teaming up with
smite and that battle pass is now
available
but if you're wondering what's next for
smite check out this announcement
okay let's see who's up next here uh
look on my screen oh bug snacks
bug snacks kirokiro bonito
uh anybody know uh is bug snacks plural
um because we only have so much room
here on the stage
anybody just the stage manager here
nobody tells me anything
[Music]
try to catch up
[Music]
is
[Music]
explorer tells me they're delicious
and yes
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
then it's the story of the century
so grab a journal listen up and make
some new friends
to solve the mystery an expedition
13 stronger grandpa who all set off
seeking out a better life on snap tooth
island they designed a tasty quest
to fill the hole that many feel inside
their soul
venture deep to reach the truth and
maybe you'll learn something
you too think it sounds impossible
till you've seen a sandwich
[Music]
is
[Music]
everyone's talking about
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
strap in folks this game's for all the
marbles
he's on a breakaway this shot for the
win
yes the fans are rushing the field
and the new heavyweight champion of the
world
okay well we gotta get this show on the
road we still have
uh lots of games to show um
let's let's see here um secret
world exclusives secrets
wait you can't keep secrets from the
stage manager people
ah what's the difference stand by for
day of the devs in three two one
who's it oh hello no don't be scared
what is day of the devs come inside the
box and you'll find out
freak yes this way
ah yeah no down here down here
great great welcome to my home would you
care for azima
[Music]
but what is day of the devs i'm glad you
asked day of the devs is a showcase of
great indie titles that we've selected
for you to check out because we think
they're really special we know there's a
lot of games out there we don't want you
to miss the
really best ones and a chance to meet
some of the great developers who are
putting them together
um we have been doing this show with our
friends at imatepit for about eight
years
here in san francisco it's free and
people can come and check out games and
meet developers
but unfortunately we're all locked in
our homes or our little cardboard boxes
this year
and so doing some digital shows we did
one in june and it was so successful so
many
submissions they're so great we couldn't
fit them all into one show so we're
doing a special july show
to share um more with you so um without
further ado please check out these games
and put them on your wish list and enjoy
first up is uh ghost runner from one
more level in poland there's a ton of
amazing games coming out of poland right
now and this is another great example of
it
uh it's a first person platformer with
uh frequent deaths
a lot of trying to find your perfect run
and perfect path through it
and it's gorgeous enjoy hello everyone
my name is radek gratusnik we are one
more level a team
of 30 people who are working really hard
to deliver you some fresh
hardcore first person action experience
set in the post-apocalyptic cyberpunk
world
ghost runner
the action takes place inside a giant
megastructure
called dharma tower which is the place
where the last remnants of humanity
shelter after the cataclysm called the
burst
that destroyed most of the life on earth
the player takes control over ghost
who is a heavily augmented combat
specialist and bodyguard
prisoner's right level extremely high
who suddenly
wakes up many years after a coup his
goal
is to reach the top of the tower and
deal with the current ruler
the key master
prisoner released
[Music]
ah free at last
pleasure to meet you face to face that
is
now let's take a look inside
this may feel a little strange
welcome to cyber void time to fix you up
you can talk here by the way
who are you you can call me
architect ghostrunner also visits
cybervoid the visual representation of
dharma tower's internal network
moving through cyber void represents the
process of
hacking gaining access or otherwise
interacting with advanced computer
systems
one more thing you can use tempest to
deflect projectiles
give it a try
[Music]
like that
ghost runner is focused on melee combat
and enhanced movement abilities of our
hero
you should treat devs in ghost runner as
a part of core gameplay
is the element of learning new types of
enemies new arenas
and your character abilities
hello jack can you hear me why jack
right you wouldn't know it's the code
name we used for you during the repair
diego said you were all jacked up when
he found you and it stuck
do you mind if i call you that no
ghost runner is based on one hidden kill
mechanic
it feels really satisfying to slash
through
the enemies with your cyber katana in a
fast and precise dance of death
it's not always an easy task some
enemies require a special approach from
the player
[Music]
oh this is troublesome how do i disable
it
first you should get on top
you could probably cut it down
a media station security protocols
compromised
therma tower is completely sealed off
from the outside world
and self-sufficient capable of housing
over a million tenants when running at
full
efficiency so this is the city
wow you've never been here no
i told you the key master only allows
those loyal to her
and only a children's view
mara strictly controls the flow of
resources between the city
and the base food water
people thank you guys for watching
ghost runner is coming later this year
pc
ps4 and xbox one please follow us on
all kind of social medias and it would
be great if you could add us
on your steam wishes bye every culture
has their own lore
passed on from generation to generation
what i grew up with
is different from what you grew up with
our next game is from leap game studios
they're out of peru
and they're sharing with us all the
mythological creatures and monsters that
they grew up with
in the form of an amazonian badass beat
up that is so well animated that hurts
my name is jorge garcia i'm from libya
studios based in peru and i'm the game
director for tunshi
[Music]
toonchild is a 2d beaten up game in the
best traditions of all school classics
like stress of rage and final fights
but it is also inspired by faster and
more modern hugs and slash games like
devil may cry
all of these within a world based on a
macedonian popular
and can be played alone or in co-op
one of conscious main features is its
robust and fast-paced combat
full of combo possibilities and flashing
magic attacks
each of our five characters have their
own combat
style and also in the future of the game
you might find a familiar face hat hit
from a hat in time
who is a guest character on our game
since dunche is procedurally generated
we don't expect players
to beat all of its levels and bosses in
one go
everything you will see in duncher has
been hand-drawn
frame by frame
all the game's bosses are based on real
tales of studies
villagers tell their children if they
behave poorly or if they want to spare
them a little bit
[Music]
so
thank you for taking the time to check
out our game don't forget to try out
tuncharena
which is a demo available right now and
if you enjoy it don't forget to add
conchae to your esteemed wish list
thank you girls mate games is a group
based here in the bay area that runs
summer camps for young aspiring game
developers to jam together and hone
their game development skills
we've showcased their talents at our
main shows many times over the years and
so it felt like a natural fit to include
them in today's lineup
you'll see them scattered throughout our
show today let's check out what the next
generation of game developers has been
up to
hi everyone my name is laila shabir i'm
the founder and ceo of girls night games
we're super honored to be presenting
here at day of the devs thanks to double
fine and team schaefer
the girls make games runs summer camps
and workshops where we teach
girls ages 8 through 18 how to design
and program their own video games our
campers learn everything that goes into
making a fully functional prototype
[Music]
the best part about camp really is the
community so many of our campers will be
like i had no idea there were so many
girls like me out there
i love going to camp because i don't
feel as crazy having played
undertale like 15 times i'm not kidding
that's a real story
[Music]
so the top five games are presented to a
panel of judges
and and the winner gets a grand prize
which is basically getting your game
kick started
professionally developed and then
published today i want to talk to you
about two games that were grand prize
winners in the past at girls make games
the first one is find me a 2017
grand prize winner
you play as a shadow that has been
separated
from your person
the aesthetics are inspired by a limbo
the girls were pretty open about that
and they they wanted the player to kind
of go through a journey to discover
themselves and discover their dreams and
aspirations
before finally finding the body
team and venue did such an incredible
job they're a group of teen girls
avalon audrey maeve and katie
but the game is coming out this year and
they're insanely excited
the game went on to raise over thirty
thousand dollars on kickstarter which is
kind of incredible it's one of our
highest grossing kickstarters
you should definitely check it out when
it comes out later this year it's going
to launch on steam first and then later
on consoles
our next thing isn't exactly a new game
but it's
related to a really [ __ ] popular one
i'm john i'm the co-owner of i'm eight
bit
and for the last eight years we've been
producing day of the devs with our
friends at double fine
the imei bits also known for making
premium collectibles for your favorite
indies
that includes physical games vinyl
records other rad stuff
we care deeply about quality however
we don't like waste so for the last year
we've been quietly developing
eco-friendly packaging for all of our
premier products
this is what we're calling the lovely
edition of the untitled goose game for
playstation 4.
it's made of 100 post consumer waste
material
all the components inside this and the
switch version
are 100 recyclable and made from
sustainable sources
the sticker included is made from a
sugar based material
we're also applying the same principles
to vinyl records
this right here looks like a bowl of
fruity pebbles but it's
actually ground up pieces of used
reclaimed vinyl it'll be re-melted
into brand new vinyl records that will
play perfectly on your turntable
every copy of until the goose game will
be made from this grind
and all the jackets and even the shrink
wrap will be eco-friendly
100 recyclable think about this like the
alpha version of our eco-friendly
packaging
we really wanted to start the
conversation now because it takes a
while to enact change
a year from now two years from now we
can look upon this as the very
beginnings the first step
of something that was important this eco
packaging has been a labor of
love in collaboration with househouse
and panic
and the best part is you can pre-order
it right now on imeba.com
the playstation 4 version the nintendo
switch version and the vinyl soundtrack
we're also bringing untitled goose game
to global retail
and to do that we're partnering with our
friends at skybound games
to expand our distribution reach
exponentially
this means more indie games that are
artful and beautiful and inspiring
in more hands more people discovering
important games like this
we are so pumped we made a trailer to
celebrate
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
remember airports they were fun weren't
they running to catch your flight
through a maze of endless identical
corridors whilst emotionless voices bark
orders at you from the sky
our next game captures that emotion
perfectly it's called an
airport for aliens currently run by dogs
hi i'm zoeva nelson jr for the micro
studio strange scaffold and i'm making
an airport for aliens currently run by
dogs
with an incredible team of people around
the world
[Music]
[Laughter]
airports broke my brain back when they
existed so
we're now making an absurd first person
open world comedy adventure game about
navigating a universe of simulated
airports
run by stock photo dogs where you can
pet any dog at any time
with an infinite number of hands
[Music]
the airports you travel through they are
evolving
as you travel their store locations the
dogs you can meet the objectives you
need to complete
are constantly changing with you making
no two playthroughs
play the same
and i'm gonna get real for a second
living sucks right now like the concept
of existing
is really rough no pun intended so i'm
deeply thankful to be making
a game set in a universe that is
unapologetically joyful
and kinda
[Laughter]
just go back and ask a dog for another
boarding pass
like dogs don't care about money
unless your bribe dog the dog who cares
about bribes but we're going to talk
about his crimes later
[Laughter]
this is a world filled with creatures
that are glad to meet you glad you're
here whether or not you help them
with their strange problems
i'm glad you're here and i can't wait to
introduce you all to this universe that
has made me
love making games again when it comes to
pc and consoles this holiday
thank you so much for watching
next up is unto the end from two ton
studios this is a husband and wife team
out of canada
now living in san diego and this game
has a really
unique combat system all about tells and
dodging
it's really easy to pick up and play but
difficult to master and always kind of
evolving
i think the most exciting thing to me is
that it reminds me a lot of another
world one of my favorite games that
every scene is totally handcrafted and
different from the last
so you never know what to expect hey
guys i'm sarah hey guys steven here
together we're two ton studios and today
we're going to show you a bit of our
game on to the end
under the end is a combat adventure game
in the style of a cinematic platformer
it's all about a father that's trying to
fight his way back home to his family
yeah fight is the key word lots and lots
of fighting
there's also no hud no loading screens
we hand crafted the world
kind of as one long canvas everything is
purpose place
every rock is unique every piece of
architecture
is got more behind it it's there for a
reason
we spent almost the first year maybe
even more just working on the combat
system
we designed it specifically for 2d but
we still wanted it to feel
really heavy and deliberate this is not
a button master
read and react
every action really matters we want to
capture that feeling of being in a sword
fight
the the sweaty palms yeah the intensity
the needing to stay calm
in the moment and make the most of every
opportunity
in some cases fighting isn't your only
option or even your
best option
you can trade with creatures you can
leave some creatures alone
those decisions really shape the story
and adventure
will be slightly different exactly
it really is about the struggle and how
you as the player are gonna make it home
thanks so much to double fine and i am
8bit extremely cool to be part of day of
the devs
absolutely thanks so much guys our
second game from girls make games
is a rather familiar setting for most of
us
it takes place in school and there might
be some bullies involved
the second game that i want to talk to
you about is shredded secrets
the hallways are always full of bullies
i feel like
everyone is out to get me seriously it
takes a really cool anti-bullying stance
and and the girls kind of came up with
the concept loosely based on experiences
they'd had in middle school themselves i
remember grandma always took me for ice
cream when i came home crying
she always knew how to cheer me up
you play as four different characters so
you kind of get to live the lives of
four
individuals at a middle school three of
whom are
students and one teacher
leslie and i used to go to the arcade
together
it was the last time i felt comfortable
in my own skin
i miss those days nobody likes me
not even the teacher i'm not a person to
them just a problem they solved
they don't care why i am what i am their
lives intertwine you kind of go through
problems together
you battle with your you know biggest
obstacles in your life and you kind of
resolve your problems in meaningful and
productive ways
one of the best parts about this game is
that it helps you build empathy and i
think
this is literally what we talk about
when we say girls perspective is so
unique because young girls are thinking
about these things and they want to make
games
that inspire people to be better they
want to make games that help
you see what it might be like to be in
someone else's shoes
[Music]
and to be doing that while you're in
middle school is kind of impressive
shredded secrets was created by team
sarcastic shark clouds
and the incredible team members are
crystal gracie isadora
and kira check out their game and give
them a thumbs up on steam when you see
it
our games are out on ichio and steam our
mission here is to empower girls
to believe that they can do anything
that they want to do and to be able to
showcase these games at
something like day of the devs is just a
huge honor so thank you all so much for
watching and
we'll see you we'll see you at game
launches thank you
for this july showcase we are excited to
debut
a few games from a brand new indie
publisher called
mwm interactive this next one is from a
developer called hidden fields
and it is meticulously hand drawn by a
single
human being literally like everything in
this game
is made by one guy every environment
every character every model it's it's
crazy
hi my name is michelle i'm the founder
of one person studio hidden fields
located here in lucerne switzerland i've
been working on this game
for six years now hand penciling every
texture that appears in the game
now with this exclusive video i can
finally introduce you to the world i've
created
it's full of mystery horror strange
encounters
and places to explore welcome to mundane
[Music]
so
hi i'm johnny dylanic and i'm the
developer of grief film
a hearts crave conflict
they long for war
they wish to be freed
released from the curse of peaceful rest
your film is a tense dueling game about
proving your worth through combat
i was inspired by the pick up and play
nature of party games like mid-hog
but also the deep combat system of games
like mountain blade
mordhau and for honor so i wanted combat
to be
easy to pick up yet hard to master
you can attack high mid or low and also
block high mid or low
you also have abilities to shove counter
attack
to more faint basically making it a
dance to
death as you block your opponent and
find the right opportunity to strike him
down
you can play grief film and couch co-op
or online with up to four players
set up teams or go free for all in
several different modes
three film also has a dynamic repeatable
campaign that you can play
in single player or with a friend in
couch co-op
[Music]
and new abilities equipment and enemies
shift and change from run to run
[Music]
the campaign features a dynamic
narrative system
which unfolds the story differently for
each player
[Music]
each run is a new journey and you
uncover the mysteries of this
battle-scarred land
after over two years of development i
can finally announce that the game will
be coming out on steam on the 20th of
august
join our community on discord at discord
gg
grief film and don't forget to wishlist
on steam one of my most
favorite games of the last decade is
called hohokum it's this wonderful
strange
colorful charming whimsical game
this next game is from the developers of
hohokum holopons and richard hogg
and publishers annapurna interactive
it's equally as colorful
and strange and weird and amazing and
curious
it is called i am dead
this is shelbuston a small
but remarkable island in the north
atlantic
with a long strange history
oh i'm morris lupton i've lived here
all my life i've been curating the
stories of this
unique place for years and ah
here it is my museum
but lately well it seems like i can do
new things
[Music]
and well it's not a big deal but i
should mention
at this point i am
dead hello i'm richard hogg
and i'm ricky haggett together we worked
on the games ho hocum and wilmot's
warehouse and we want to tell you about
our next game
it's called i am dead and will be
published by annapurna interactive
i am dead is a puzzle adventure game you
play as morris
the curator of a small local museum who
just happens to be dead
since dying you see the world a bit
differently as you're able to peer
inside objects it's a bit like having
supernatural x-ray vision
you can even see memories inside
people's heads together with your dog
sparky
who is also dead you use your ghostly
powers to reveal secrets
solve puzzles and meet other ghosts
the island has a volcano beneath it
which has been dormant
but now it's beginning to wake up and
it's up to morris and sparky to save the
place they called home
so what does the player actually do in
this game
well it's hard i am dead's a unique kind
of hidden object game where you use your
ghostly ability to see inside things
as you examine things you get to see
them in a kind of dynamic cross-section
and the player has full control over
this and it feels very
fluid and intuitive it's a new way of
looking at objects
a lot of these things are just kind of
beautiful and mesmerizing when you see
them like this
look inside this sculpture it's like an
abstract sculpture
but the insides are so cool and you can
drill down inside things there are
things inside things inside things to
find but yeah most importantly there are
specific things that the player is
supposed to be looking for like this
horse grooming glove
a horse grooming glove yeah it belonged
to your old friend val when she was
alive
it's been stolen by this fox who loves
stealing gloves
perfectly normal behavior for a fox
[Music]
what's your favorite thing to look at in
this game probably this toaster
yeah i like that one too
let's talk about why you have to find
these specific things
it's to do with the other ghosts you're
dead and so are they and
in order to talk to them you need to
find a bunch of objects that meant
something to them when they were alive
we call these things mementos and the
reason you have to talk to these other
dead folks is that between you all
you might be able to stop the volcano
erupting and destroying the island
we need to talk about the different
kinds of people you meet in this game
there are some interesting characters
yeah obviously there are local islanders
then there are these fish folk
who are a race of aquatic people who
live in the sea around the island
a different kind of local they've only
recently been coming ashore and wearing
clothes and stuff like that
adopting human ways and then people have
been visiting the island from elsewhere
for various reasons
the lighthouse is now a thriving yoga
retreat and there's a sculpture park
that attracts some of the biggest names
in contemporary arts
why is this guy an apple oh that's
vernon russet he's a famous sculptor
and also a braeburn
i like these bird characters yeah
they're all tourists from the island of
tia paquito
they literally flock here in large
numbers every summer especially since
the new ferry has been coming to the
island
well they take the ferry can't they just
fly not with all that camera equipment
no
[Music]
this is a game about ghosts but we don't
think of them as ghosts really they
aren't spooky at all
it's really a game about normal people
who just happen to be dead
the stories of their lives told through
the memories of people who knew them
and the objects that they left behind
you have to find these hidden objects
that meant something to them and in
order to know what you're looking for
you delve inside the memories of people
who knew them when they were alive
and discover stories that they remember
about that person
each memory tells you a little story and
also gives you a clue as to which object
you are looking for
you also get to talk to the ghosts once
you have found them and of course you
are always talking to your faithful dog
sparky
she's very cold it's sparky
maurice you worked it out oh
you can talk well i could always talk
you just couldn't understand me she's
kind of your spirit guide
she has a better grip on what's going on
in the afterlife than you do to be
honest
okay thanks for watching our little film
about i am dead
we hope you enjoy it when it comes out
thanks for watching
[Music]
it's important to keep an open mind
while checking out this next game
it's a surreal puzzle adventure set
inside the perilous human
psyche where ethics and morals will
reshape your world view
it's also a folk musical this is figment
creed valley
hey everyone i'm hans from bedtime and
i'd like to show you guys
figment creed valley the encore to our
previous game figment
creed valley the mind's world view is
maintained here right
looks pretty much as i remember it the
game takes place in the human mind
the moral compass has been shattered
making the mind
unable to function properly it's up to
dusty the courage of the mind
to find the culprit and restore peace
creed valley is where the minds ideals
and morals are formed
principle squares for opinions only none
shall pass
the opinions don't act the same when
open and close-minded
let's find a mind converter it's
populated by opinions on all kinds of
important subjects
like if the toilet seat should be left
up or down
[Music]
we can't pass the eye bridge as long as
the mind is open you can switch between
open and close-minded which shifts
everything around you
the plants the trees the houses and even
how the opinions interact with you
shifts everyone should be able to move
everywhere freely please pass the bridge
yay
open-minded all the way open-minded is a
welcoming state
where the mind is set in to take new
perspectives
oh no what's this the opinion on justice
has been knocked out cold
very mysterious must be because the
moral compass is broken
close minded is where the mind gets
things done it might seem
a bit more hostile though the sun's not
yellow it's chicken
i try to apply colors like words that
shape homes like notes that shape music
but the mind actually needs both to
properly work
oh yeah and by the way the games are
musicals
dodge and weave in theatrical showdowns
so as you explore the world you'll also
be adding layers to the music you hear
[Music]
around
thanks a lot for watching
we've been friends with the gang at us
two games since they released their
breakout hit
monument valley their games are always
curiosity inspiring
tons of exploration and innovation and
always
oozing with beautiful art what's crazy
is they've never released a
multi-platform console game
until now we have the debut trailer
and this is one you're going to want to
freeze frame it goes by fast
lots of clues hidden throughout
[Music]
hello i'm david fernandez from astor
games the people behind the monument
valley games and more recently assembled
with care
over the last couple of years we've been
secretly working on our biggest game yet
but the project started really small
with a tiny team of just two myself and
my colleague kirsten kitz
who is an amazing programmer and
designer we were able to start something
that was very
special to us very personal something
that captures the magic of the
mediterranean summers of our childhood
and also our love for nature and now
with a team full of incredibly talented
people
the game has grown beyond our wildest
dreams
i have a little tease here for you and i
really hope you like it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh next up is void terrain from new york
studios a distributed team
uh and this game is a unique one uh
you're piloting a train through an empty
void
exploring this world and finding
materials to craft and upgrade your
train
ultimately to explore these really
surreal landscapes
hey everybody my name is dima and i'm
the publishing producer at nyarco
studios
we're a studio of 12 people scattered
all across the world
and we're making weight training
[Music]
[Music]
voidtrain is an action-packed survival
game where you manage your
own interdimensional train while
traveling through the void across
the world you ride your train through
the void and enter portals that lead
from one world to the next each world is
a little different
[Music]
some have tough enemies you fire off
evil nazi soldiers
they are trying to chase you to take
your loot away from you
others have flying islands you can
explore and look
fly around your train on a safety rope
collecting materials around
while the train is still moving
there are many dangers that can sneak up
sky mines void beasts
[Music]
[Music]
materials are needed to craft
workbenches
you upgrade your train from a simple
trolley
into a large and beautiful diesel or
tesla locomotive
for a long time we wanted to make a game
that is unique
in its setting and feels crazy fun to
play and we hope
to achieve that vision with waitrain
to learn more about the game visit our
steam page
check out the game's features and don't
forget to wishlist it if you like what
you see
thank you bye bye next up is mequodus
from huey games face down to manchester
um this is a super cute super charming
game set in a world of gears where you
play as this
really adorable gear man
enjoy hello i'm rob from huey games and
we
are delighted to share this world
exclusive
debut of mechanus with you today
[Music]
in mechanists you embark on a clockwork
adventure set in a mechanical ecosystem
as cognito a curious creature whose duty
to maintain
the life cycle of this captivating world
leads him on a journey to the heart of
the machine
in order to save it
in this metallic jungle where life is
mechanical rather than biological in
nature
evolution has given rise to a
beautifully orchestrated set of
behaviors
which underpin the tactile clockwork
puzzles and dynamic platforming of the
game
[Music]
the distinct character design of cognito
creates the opportunity for expressive
emotional responses to the events
unfolding around him which can also act
as prompts for the player
building a strong connection between
player and avatar which enriches the
sense of immersion in this fantastical
world
as you roll through the apparatus of
each unique region you will unlock
compelling characters and incredible new
abilities
while turning the gears of a beautifully
crafted narrative
which revolves around interconnection
and symbiosis between life forms
the environment and the flow of
resources which feed them
we can't wait to share more details
about the world of mechanisms with you
so join us on the journey on the huey
games discord
to interact with the developers and keep
up to date with all the latest news
thank you for watching and stay safe
it's really wild to see how vr has
evolved over the last couple years
people are really embracing the
technology trying new and different
things
publisher mwm interactive and developer
interspace vr
have this game called mask maker and the
concept is
really rad uh just take a look
hello i'm baltazar creative director of
innerspace vr
i'm proud to share with you the very
first glimpse of our new project
mask maker we've been working on very
hard since the last few months
i hope you will be curious to see more
and get as excited about the game
as we are now i let prospero the mask
maker
speak let's jump in
i see you apprentice
now it is time to show you how i see the
world
sometimes especially recently it feels
like we're living in a nightmare
luckily we can seek solace in our dreams
as we sleep at night
sadly not so for the hero of this next
game who must face her fears and do
battle with negative emotions while she
slumbers
or die trying this is dreamscaper
hey everyone my name is ian from
afterburner studios and along with my
two partners
we make dreamscaper
dreamscaper is an action rpg roguelite
you'll play as cassidy a woman whose
sleep is restless and fitful
as she comes to terms with her past
during the day you'll travel across the
city of red haven
you'll meet new friends and foster
relationships with them
[Music]
unlocking story vignettes and new powers
at night you'll dive into her
subconscious
exploring ever-changing dreamscapes
taking on her nightmares
and discovering lost memories
you'll have an expansive combat system
to help guide cassidy through her dreams
as she faces off against nightmarish
manifestations
of her most negative emotions
[Music]
we can't wait for you to dispel the
darkness of cassie's nightmares
when dreamscaper launches into early
access next month
on steve
[Music]
we promised a lot of world exclusive
surprises in this july showcase
and this next one is from a rather
popular indie game franchise
called blasphemous this is the
continuation
of the saga
hola michael
foreign
[Music]
strategies
[Music]
[Music]
from your flasks thereby enhancing its
gift
potential
includes
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
the state of town
i am i'm not sure how to get out of this
box
that's very tiny i think i need some
help
help help
thanks for watching the day of the devs
summer games fest developer showcase
extra special thanks to all of our
generous sponsors it takes so many
people to make a broadcast like this
possible
especially during a pandemic playstation
idea xbox
nintendo epic game store steam we are so
grateful
you've always been there for us you're
awesome super extra special thanks to
bion
creative director over at q games and
also composer
for pixeljunk eden2 and by the way
the day the devs is coming back in
november
subscribe to our email list at
daviddevs.com
check in on social we'll be announcing
dates in the coming months
and we're going to be looking for
submissions so please
send us your awesome indies thanks again
for watching
stay tuned for another musical
performance all right well the show is
over people uh
baeon is going to take us out with a
musical performance
um so here they are all the way from
japan
i sure hope someone checked his wi-fi
connection and i think
i'm gonna take a break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
wait is it is it recording it's already
recording it's not sticking anymore
it's just like not sticking it might
cover that window up a little bit around
okay i will only open this one wait lily
show me is it videoed is it recording
yes okay hold on look it's not it's a
little bit
sideways you gotta look at me so i'm
gonna clap this way yeah
okay look at my see my hands
i hope that works it made the school
fall off
okay we gotta we're gonna have to go for
it as is
ready okay go back to the door and we'll
start
okay
i think you just need more tape maybe
we'll just lean it over here on the side
let's do that okay okay
by the wind here i know put it here and
i'll you're gonna hold up my finger
no but i can see your finger very easily
no just lean it there pull your hand
back i have an idea
yeah okay
let's see if that works okay sorry
anyone who's watching this that's
it's taking so long okay
you